louis lapham this is the time of year
when people traditionally look back and
look ahead but we are entering uh 1984
which has a long time an american
society been a year that we've looked
ahead to because of george orwell's
predictions as we get close to 1984 are
we in fact close to the society that
george orwell envisioned
no i don't think so i think we're going
the other way i think that the orwell as
you remember envisioned a society a very
static world there were three large
omnipotent totalitarian states
everything was controlled
big brother could look at you through
the television screen
there were thought police
very little personal freedom of any kind
decisions were centrally organized
it was a kind of
perfect
well-run efficient bureaucracy
now
if i look around at the world i see the
world as a very
quite the opposite sort of place very
fluid
mr reagan has trouble controlling the
rumors coming out of his own white house
switchboard
there is an underground economy in the
united states worth roughly 400 billion
dollars
there are several million people in the
united states that whose names appear on
nobody's lists
the
far from being a kind of
large power world
the
initiative seems to me to have shifted
to the smaller concentrations of power
so that you get
a
diplomatic crisis being being
provoked by
libyan terrorists by the plo by states
as small as israel or syria
and
i think that the orwellian view is is a
bureaucrat's dream it's a nightmare
dream but it still
appeals to the bureaucratic and to the
literary mind because it is a world
controlled by by uh
words not by things
and uh
i see them i see the world
in a state of flux
and revolution and excitement not uh not
stace stasis and
despair which was
orwell's idea good morning from
washington our guest this morning is
lewis lapham he is an
author a lecturer syndicated columnist
but perhaps best known as editor of
harper's magazine the nation's oldest
monthly publication we're going to be
talking this morning with him about
george orwell in 1984 because over the
past
over the past couple days and again
through the weekend we're going to be
covering the smithsonian symposium on
1984 and this afternoon mr lapham is
going to be one of the panelists we'll
talk about that perhaps you can even
give him some input into the speech that
he'll be delivering at that session and
as always during this hour we'll be
looking at the morning headlines and ask
you to pick up your morning newspaper
look at what's on the front page and
give us a call in our studios i'll give
you the telephone numbers right now and
we'll continue to talk here and as a
question comes to mind please join us in
the discussion for those of you who live
in the eastern and central time zones
the number that you dial area code 202
628-2525 viewers in the pacific and
mountain and time zones should use area
code 202
783-2727 please do keep in mind however
that we do have a one month telephone
policy if you've reached the studio
within that time hold off and give
others a chance
i'd like to start off with the the
column in in the january 84 edition
appropriate considering our george
orwell discussion that you wrote it is a
letter to the reader
the easy chair it's called
notes on a newer journalism
and you talk about your readership in
this article and how they are perhaps
small but a very vocal group and compare
those with the mass audience of the
larger media
read a quick paragraph and ask you to
respond in edward r mero's generation it
was necessary to send out for the news
now the news beats down the doors
besieging the offices of the media with
an uproar of fact and opinion the media
have no choice but to become agents of
interpretation but on what basis and
with what purpose in mind can you
elaborate on this the the job the role
of the news media as a result of what
you've said
well i think the role of the news media
is is is changing and should be changing
i think it becomes necessarily an
interpretive role
because if you go to
any day uh any hour there is so much
news there are so many places that you
could send a camera or send a reporter
or
that you don't it's like it's coming at
you all the time and the question is of
course
how to organize this on
and that is a problem that i think that
the media will begin to address i don't
think that
we've addre well we've addressed it in
some special interest magazines for the
last 20 years the information has been
broken down into very very small
categories so that one of the most
successful magazines in america for
example is called the american beagle
which deals with beagle dogs and but
that
tends to if you fragment it that way
it still doesn't give a sense of the
whole or a coherence as to what fits
with what or so in your estimation the
american consumer of news wants
interpretation
i think so he doesn't want to be
lectured to i think one of the reasons
for the for a hostility toward the media
is it is the media's sanctimony is the
pretense to have answers
in other words i think the media also
has to take the stance of a
uh
guide and friend to the to the consumer
to the to the audience rather than a
presiding conscience i don't think the
i don't think the reader wants to be
told what to think i think the reader
wants to be told that
this piece of information goes with this
piece of information
also the
you know what are the reasons for our
being for example in lebanon and
what is
the relation of the political world to
the
economic world i mean or and to the
cultural world i think they're all
of a same piece so is it possible to be
a conscientious reporter
to do what you have described and fit
the pieces together without becoming
sanctimonious i think so yeah and i
think that the
[Music]
if you take two
pieces of information and put them next
to each other and say look at this look
at that
and sort of leave it to the reader to
make up his or her mind i think you can
do it without being
officious about it you see i think that
it's possible to do that the journalism
goes through fashion so that
25 years ago we had something called the
new journalism which which really was
something that we also had
in the 1920s but it came back into vogue
and that put the journalist himself or
herself very much in the foreground as a
celebrity and as a star
and it's that that i think is is
changing that people would rather
that the journal journalists got a
little bit out of the light if you see
what i mean and
try can we do that with the electronic
media
i guess there's ways to do that i think
so i think you you try and do that on on
this kind of a show it seems to me
it's hard to do with big production
values and it's hard to do with uh
it's difficult for the networks to do it
but i think that they're trying i mean i
think that that's the
underlying basis of something like ted
koppel's nightline or
the mcneil lehrer report i think that
it's
moving in that direction
this magazine
i'd like to especially invite people in
the audience who read harper's to phone
us and tell us what you think of it for
those that have never picked it up in
the news stand or aren't subscribers
what are you trying to do with this
magazine
well i'm going to change it
you're looking at the
january issue and then we do one more
issue in this format and then in march
we will change the whole magazine
and i will try to do
just what i've told you i'm going to try
to do so that the
first thing that will
i'm going to try to put pieces of
information together in a way that will
have meaning and coherence i hope
and
that requires a whole different design
one of the things i'm going to do for
example is is
have a
something called the harper's index
which will be a page of
facts taken out of the last month for
example the number of tons of oil
spilled in the indian ocean
the price of cocaine in los angeles
the last sale of
a painting at sotheby's
the number of uh
politicians arrested in florida
the number of attempts on hussein's life
jordan something like that and if i put
down a list of 50
things it's like taking a
test boring into the
into the
current scene
and
if you put them together in interesting
ways it at least gives people a sense of
the whole you know for example if you if
you know that this is going on in the
indian ocean you know that this is going
on in los angeles
number of tons of shipping in the in the
pearl river for example in
china will give you
some feeling of what's going on and then
i'll after that i'll take 20 pages of
the magazine
i can go on very long with this susan if
you want me to because it's a whole
scheme
all right let's we have a caller on the
line and we'll go back to the next 20
pages in the magazine jacksonville
florida good morning your first caller
yes good morning i'm speaking about the
media and the week before the grenada
invasion uh not a time magazine news we
covered a big spread crisis in the
caribbean the french news media sigma
picked up on this their international
letters sent the news team down to
granada well lo and behold they happened
to be there for an invasion picked up a
prime story i don't see why the american
news media in behind their international
desk couldn't do the same thing they
just got out professionalized by your
european columnist so what they've done
is they blamed the american government
for inefficiency from missing the boat
i mean all the intelligence was right
there in front of them they even had it
right on their international desk they
didn't follow up on it they weren't
there for a story so now they're saying
the federal government stopped them from
going to granada the french just outdid
the american news media thank you thank
you
response
he's right
following up on that because i'd like to
talk a bit more about this morning in
the the washington talk briefing page of
the new york times there is a little
piece called delicate balance and it
says letters went out this week to
associations of print and broadcast
journalists asking each to name a
representative to serve on a committee
that will weigh the interest of the
military in maintaining security in any
operation against the interests of
reporters and photographers covering
such an operation
any thoughts about the necessity for a
committee such as that and what impact
it might have
well i'm not so sure the committee will
have an impact
the
way to get if the reporters want to get
on the
be part of the operation or get close to
the invasion they just have to badger
people a lot i mean
the committee approaches seems to me a
little bit
of a bureaucratic one
and sometimes in its larger
manifestations the the media gets very
bureaucratic and as the gentleman
pointed out and also kind of lazy
does you've used the word bureaucracy
when we've been talking about 1984 and
also several times in past comments is
that necessarily a bad thing a
bureaucracy
no it's not i mean it becomes unwieldy
if it gets too large
uh
bureaucracy is is necessary i mean i
don't quite well
i think it's at least under the present
formulations it's it's necessary and
it's large
manifestations people rather like
bureaucracy as a matter of fact they
like to go to work in a bureaucracy
it's not a it's not i don't mean it as a
pejorative term it's a
when i i use the word as a definition
for an organization that necessarily has
many levels of
administration and authority and is
charged with doing
more tasks than
it usually can perform as an observer of
the american society were you surprised
at the outcry among members of the media
about the exclusion from grenada
were they justified in your estimation
in being outraged
i i think so i think they
were justified yeah i think the media
has to
push for whatever it can get i mean it
can't
rely on it being given to them i can
also understand the the government's
interest in trying to keep them
off the invasion fleet
because they didn't know of course what
they were going to find and in the
present
circumstances when
images can be transmitted so rapidly on
television
that the diplomacy
is a different thing than it was
when there was a period of space and
time you don't have that
luxury
so
a particularly offensive picture let us
say of an american soldier
killing a grenadian or vice versa
could have within a matter of hours
brought pressure to bear on
mr reagan and and
perhaps state his hand you don't and so
that it is in the interest of the
administration of course not to
whenever it can to try to manage
the theatrics of diplomacy go back to
the phones for lewis lapham rochester
new york good morning good morning
children do you have your morning
newspaper sir no i don't i want to make
a comment on harper's new format okay do
you read it regularly uh no i don't read
it regularly but my wife brings it in
frequently from the library
and i i'm not a subscriber but i will
welcome that new format you know i think
the best editorial page that gives us
both sides of the picture is in usa
today
but it seems as though they're from the
extremes
of of our political spectrum and so i
think if you give the facts and all the
facts and let the reader make up his own
mind he's going to welcome that idea
himself
and i certainly will welcome your new
format i'm delighted to hear it because
i
you confirm my sense of what the what i
think people
want to
read
so what kind of a market or an outlet do
you think that the new harpers will have
who are you trying to reach with this
i'm trying to reach uh what can i go on
a little bit about after my first page
then comes my then comes 20 pages of a
it's a summary section a portfolio in
which i will include
passages from all kinds of
texts that the readers might not have
seen in other words it could be a few
hundred words from the bulletin of
atomic scientists or an editorial from
the nation
a piece from le mans a cartoon from a
soviet newspaper
the text of a speech that a government
official may have given in idaho and has
not been covered
i mean we are surrounded by fascinating
texts and documents and relatively few
of them make it into the large media
just because it's difficult for them to
do that
and i can now begin to do these kind of
things
because of the computers you see i can
set up type that way and i i will we our
editors will read three or four hundred
magazines a month looking for
for
perceptive
texts and documents and we will publish
them in the original voice i mean you
know we'll translate it from the french
or the russian but
but we won't attempt to rewrite the uh
what it says in the nation or what it
says in the new england journal of
medicine again you leave it up to the
reader i'm assuming that the readers are
more intelligent and
then
they're sometimes given credit for in
the by the marketing people in new york
oakdale pennsylvania good morning you're
our next caller
hold on just a second i'll turn down my
television okay
first off where is oakdale oakdale is 11
miles southwest of pittsburgh
pennsylvania okay what's on your mind i
can make two comments okay first of all
i would like to comment all of you hosts
for your call-in programs i think you do
a marvelous job a spectacular job under
the stress you are presented with and
secondly i would like to compliment mr
lapham i have long been a fan of his
in his role as the editor of harper's
magazine i was demolished when he left
i did not like
harper's
under the editorship of that other
person whom i will not name but i am
most delighted to find that mr lapin has
resumed his vote and i look forward
to his
i know it will be marvelous i can't tell
you how happy mr wrapped my hand to you
back well i thank you very much i was
just about to cancel my subscription as
a matter of fact last month save just in
time
and here you are and i will stay with
you as long as you are there thank you
welcome back before you go tell us what
specifically about the magazine it is
that attracts you
uh the literary mind of mr lassen
that's simply stated okay thank you for
the telephone call i mentioned to
viewers that you are participating in
the session that we will be covering
which is the smithsonian symposium
which is a tribute to george orwell the
session that you are participating in if
i can find my paper here is this
afternoon at 2 30 eastern time if you're
interested in tuning in it is on
learning the responsibilities of
citizenship in an open society your
particular category is education
right what tack will you take
well i'm going to take they're going to
they're putting to me the question can
you teach citizenship in the schools and
uh
my answer to that is probably not in
other words i i think you have to learn
citizenship
in the open society and in the arenas of
politics or the pits of trade or
the
corridors of the media or wherever you
happen to be i mean i think it's a
lifelong study
and
i don't think it's something you can put
on the schools if you put if you try to
get the schools to
teach
that sort of thing you
end up with philosopher kings or you end
up with people who come out of the
schools with a great many abstractions
in their mind
relatively little experience of other
people
and then they
if they manage to get
hold of power as we've noticed over the
last 300 sorry last 30 years when
professors come to washington
and try to implement theories
the results are usually
unpleasant
i mean it it's based on
uh if it's
action is based on on
too abstractive theory and not enough
experience and observation then it tends
to go wrong
and i think we've seen that with
both in foreign policy and in domestic
policy okay maybe ask for some specifics
after the next call seattle washington
good morning
uh yes i'd like to ask mr laid from you
know about his format thing so
it seems to me uh that he's taking a low
key
and it's sort of like a takeoff on the
atlantic monthly he's talking about uh
drug expose
in los angeles
miami
and such as this
and if there's a comment you know if
he's copying low-key uh
verbalism
or
such a certain you know the plan of the
day
outside of all the other discussions
uh
i'd like to wonder why he would take
such a low-key attitude with in-depth
survey
caller let me ask you we've been
discussing the merits of of news being
interpreted for you if the new harpers
will not do much interpretation of news
events is that a good thing in your mind
or a bad thing
well
i was watching this program before with
uh mr uh rowland
on c-span
and they were talking about all these
things
about the deprivation of countries like
clinical
and the uh you know it's like a toss-up
and technology
that there should be better uh media
discussion
however if we have the availability
of journalists and writers
going into that country you know it's
like
murrows you know and fascinating people
and lowell from cambodia
i'm a vietnam veteran right
so this this kind of shakes me up
like if you're behind a machine gun
you're up in the jungle
and uh all of a sudden
[Applause]
these persons or individuals
we don't know who they are
you know there's even more than cia you
know
unlimitable
funding and so he's taking a very low
key
cut
and you can find these expose
and like the atlantic monthly
so i would like to know why
he would want to take those directions
and those directions are already there
all right we'll see thank you for the
question
are you imitating a magazine that will
already be on the market no i i i'm
afraid that gentlemen has misunderstand
me it's not going to be like the
atlantic at all i mean when i said the
price of cocaine in los angeles that is
one line and one number that's not an
expose it's not it's just a fact it's
not a
it appears as a single statistic on a
single
and the
summary section in the beginning of the
magazine is is unlike anything that is
now being done except
some
variation of it is being done by the
wilson quarterly
um
after that there will be a 16-page
section which is a will be a symposium
or forum like this smithsonian thing
every month on a topic with people that
are
have different approach it from
different angles and that will also be
presented with
several
sidebars of history so that people
understand what the
i mean to simply
put
two people
discussing central america from opposite
positions
in the same debate without
a some kind of background as to
how long
the united states has been in central
america what has happened what is the
you know you see what i mean it it
it needs certain degree of historical
context and that symposium section will
have that too
talking about your your piece on
education you mentioned problems when
accommodations come to washington this
month harpers has an article called are
you listening henry kissinger an open
letter to washington's tourist in
central america
is henry kissinger
specifically one of the accommodations
that you might see problems with yes i
think so i i think kissinger is a very
brilliant man but i again
i think if you
examine his record
as a
geopolitician it isn't really very good
he is a theorist
he does deal in abstraction he has i
mean for example in the early 70s
he
totally misjudged
or ignored the likelihood of an oil
price increase
in the middle east as a result of
some of his ideas and policies i think
he also
was fooled to a certain extent by the by
the shah of around i mean
not openly deceived but i think he
thought there was more there than there
turned out to be
and what fuentes is saying in that
article is the same sort of thing here
is kissinger appointed to had the
commission on central america and
kissinger very well understands the
forms of diplomacy and how you talk to
people and what you say to the press and
so on but fuente's question is
what does he know about the substance of
central america
and
the answer is not much
or at least that's fuentes answer and i
would tend to
believe that our next caller this
morning is from columbia south carolina
good morning good morning susan
i was just
interested in your
speaker today
i'm very uh concerned about the news the
way it's presented and i don't take the
harper's bizarre but
i'm
considering it because he seems to be
the type of person that that we need in
america today some of the people you've
had on there
i've tried to get through but this is
the first time so
um i haven't been able to express my
opinion but
uh i'd like to to take his magazine if i
can afford it i i don't know the cost of
this magazine
caller let me ask you a question but
before
we learn the cost of harper's magazine
and that is the discussion that we've
been just having about
uh mr lapham's speech this afternoon at
the symposium on george orwell the
question is is it possible for our
schools to teach good citizenship do you
think that's true or not
um well
perhaps to a certain extent i think that
we ought to teach more
about america's position in the world
and uh
i i don't know i it just seems that
we're not presenting our side of
everything to our to our young people i
have a 13 year i mean 16 year old who's
in high school today and i'm not sure
she's getting
all of that information i'm not sure
she's getting
becoming aware of just
just just what we're trying to do and
where we stand in the world today is it
solely the responsibility of the schools
to teach uh young people about
america's position in the world or
should not part of it comes from the
home
and a lot of it comes from the church
and it seems today
that they're not getting a lot from the
church
and they're not getting a lot from the
homes
and the schools can't do it all but they
can
we can certainly support the schools
but i'm just interested in this man um
um i sit here at night and listen to uh
you know the news programs and
uh i get so disturbed because if it
rains in omaha mr reagan is blamed for
it you know and sometimes we get too
much opinion
uh rather than the facts and i i heard
him say he was going to have a page
solely for you know facts and
when the president speaks you know you
the newscaster comes on and he
interprets
everything the president said i mean his
way
i understand what president says and i
don't need him to do that you know so
uh that was just my comment and i thank
you thank you for the call any response
well
first of all it's harper's magazine not
harper's bizarre that's a different
magazine harper's bizarre is a fashion
magazine this one is going to is a
smaller monthly magazine
it costs two dollars on the newsstand
but i
you can subscribe to it i believe for
12 or 14 a year which is
slightly more than half the cost that
would be on the newsstand
and
i
share that caller's view about the
i think
you can teach
students in schools more than we do
about
the united states and about its history
and what it stands for
but i would teach that under the rubrics
of history and i would not
try to teach by citizenship i think what
they're asking me for in this symposium
this afternoon is is the way that
orwell would conceive that word to be an
active
participant in the public life of the
society community
state town whatever
and that
it
it's some schools teach citizenship but
they mean deportment and uh conduct and
it isn't really that that
he's talking about
immediately following this program at 10
a.m east coast time we will be taking
you to the smithsonian institution for
the second day of that symposium on
george orwell omaha nebraska good
morning you're our next caller
good morning i don't have a newspaper
but i didn't want to make an observation
about the book 1984 in a discussion
uh do you mind if i call you lou
l e w and the first initial of your last
name begins with l
and so does mine and so does little
lairman's
and if you spell it backwards it's well
and if you think of george orwell george
meaning the first father of the country
washington
you can either go that way or
wells way
that's the comment i wanted to make and
see if you had a comment on that
thank you
spent a lot of time thinking about do
you mean exposing letters he's off he's
off the line he's off the line he'll
have to deal with what he's what he said
in its entirety well maybe he meant
h.g wells and if he means h.g wells
going well's way then i would
be more inclined to go well's way than
orwell's way because i don't think that
i think it is always that if you take
night the the idea of 1984 as a metaphor
as a grim
satire you can say
it is always 1984 in some part of the
world in somebody's mind i mean and has
been in
ever since people have
been living together in civilizations i
mean
the temptation to control and to
mutilate other people is something that
can happen
in a primitive society as well as in one
with uh highly developed technology and
i don't think that the connection is
is a
is a
causal one in other words i think you
can have an orwellian world in uh
in a very primitive society and you
could have had it in ancient egypt and
you could have had it in
16th century england 17th century
england
so
we have about a half an hour left to go
with louis lapham and we won't stray too
far from the intent of this program
which is to take a look at the news
events and talk with those about you as
you phone in this is the look at the
front page of the washington post
on the
front page this morning is the delivery
of the national christmas tree to
ellipse it will be lit on the 15th other
articles on the front page the soviets
halt strategic arms talks suspension is
seen as milder than the euro missile cut
off a story by william draziak columbia
makes safe landing a story on the front
pages all across the country about the
successful flight of the columbia space
shuttle and its touchdown in california
yesterday
other stories marines unlikely to quit
beirut airport positions by fred hyatt
israel fears being drawn into a new war
in lebanon a story by edward walsh and
finally president-ending ban on military
aid and sales to argentina a look at the
front page of this morning's washington
post and we go next to los angeles
california good morning good morning how
are you fine sir do you have any of the
los angeles papers no i totally idea
okay what's on your mind then i would
like to play with a gentleman from
harper because i enjoy the magazine
tremendously i think it's very serious
and
uh has a lot of things to offer i i'm
glad he's
back talking about the orwellian world
uh
it doesn't have to come to a big
powerful government
we can come through the media
you know whenever
you look at the political the media
today it's very hard to
differentiate between entertainment and
the news media
it's a horrible
[Music]
mishmash and fish push up whatever they
put together you don't know where you're
being contained or not now i don't blame
the media for this i blame the people
who want to be entertained
and the media are studying a product
my question to the gentleman is in here
is that
in your speech today you're going to
talk about an awareness
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but the constant
bringing the newest informal
entertainment and opinion it's very hard
on people like me who are seeking for a
didactic way of life of real life from
the media
and i learned nothing
it's anything that people that you can
you can do
to bring to the media more seriousness
and more
uh intellectualism that we have right
now
thank you caller
well i think there are many attempts in
in that direction i think that this
particular show is an attempt in that
direction i think that the magazine that
i have in mind to
publish as an attempt in that direction
i think that there are
many many magazines many many journals
in this country that are
do
many things well
i think the media gets its power because
we assign it to it it's kind of like the
wizard of oz the uh it's it depends on
as you say i mean
it's not the media's fault it's the
willingness on the part of the audience
to assign to abc cbs
nbc
an omniscience and omnipotence that
those
networks really don't possess
i mean
they can be
safely ignored to a certain degree i
mean and you can read other things
that's the great
present freedom in the society now
i grant you that if if
the media
if left all to its own devices i mean
the big media could have yes it could
have
i guess it could sway
crowds and so forth and elections but
and politics is turning into a media
event but i i think the only way to go
after it is to be very aware of
what it is and what it can do and to do
as many other kinds of things
as possible
back to the phones this time tarpon
springs florida tarpon springs is off
the air okay we'll continue with our
conversation
wall street journal is the next
newspaper that we will look at this
morning
what's news in the wall street journal
the washington wire talks about rosy
forecasts of economic gains get a white
house push and resistance arab protests
about u.s israeli cooperation impel rush
patch-up efforts
this is a story over here about auto
safety agency stalls and deregulation
after setting a fast pace and over here
a burning cause a rush to martyrdom
gives iran an advantage in the war
against iraq
if we look back over the year
a big thought question for you and i'm
going to hold off on it because we do
have a caller on the line hamilton ohio
good morning you're on the air good
morning
i don't have the paper here but i would
like to discuss the speaking of fears
okay and uh
my view is that what we can teach
is how the government works
but not how it should work
uh
to give you an example
this is years ago on 59 now but when i
was in grade school
we had personal proportional
representation
in hamilton
and i remember
them setting up a system whereby we
elected people by that system so that we
understood how it worked
i don't believe the school can teach you
what you should do about it i think all
they can do is teach you how it should
work and from there on it's up to you
uh that that's all i have i have some
other ideas about the press but i'll
ignore those for the time be it thank
you thanks for the call sir
i agree with that i mean that's teaching
to my i would simply say that's part of
history or part of teaching uh how how
the government works is is essential
how does the american society fair in
terms of good citizenship as you've
described compared with other societies
well um
i really don't know the answer to that
question the i do know that that more
people vote in
let's say france or italy than than do
in the united states
[Music]
and it's very it's one of those things
it's one of those things it's very
difficult to make any kind of an
objective
assessment of it i look around and i see
a great many people who are perfectly
content to
take no part at all in the public life
and just to assume that
this is the best of all possible worlds
and to
pursue their own
ends and and
cultivate their own gardens and
that's okay but if too many people do
that without some sense of an obligation
or a duty or
a feeling for the
country as a whole or the republic
then i think that sooner or later it
it it becomes
uh it falls into the hands of people who
don't uh who simply want to use it for
their own ends in other words if the the
republican idea assumes that the
republic the the polity is a dear thing
and it's something that one seeks to
protect and
honor
and if you develop the opposite attitude
which is that government is a
rapacious worm eating your entrails or
is the
machine that is being
manipulated for the sake of the people
who can manipulate it
in other words if you develop a cynical
attitude toward the government
instead of a
respectful and
loving attitude
that's perhaps a little too strong but
it's that kind of infection
then i think sooner or later
you lose it
i think this is orwell's point and he's
saying if you once you've lost it
the nightmare becomes 1984.
scottsdale arizona good morning
good morning
thank you for see fair
i would like to uh address mr clapham
two comments maybe he could uh comment
on both of them
i hope his magazine will possibly be
made more laid out more in the format
of the mcnail lair report where we get
both sides
of an issue and let me or the reader or
watcher so to speak can make up our own
mind as to which direction we want to go
that i would like to see more mcniel
there
on tv and any media and i'm hoping he
will go that route the second thing i
would like to say possibly
i would like for him if he has the time
in wood to take the theory that russia
and the united states both get
completely out of the war game
both militaries are dropped
what would happen
to the economic situation in the united
states if we got completely out of the
war game i'd like to turn the tv up and
watch the answer please thanks for the
question scottdale scottsdale
well in the first place the answer your
first question yes there will be more
mcniel error there will be as i
explained earlier a forum in the in the
middle of the magazine we have
at least two and maybe three or four
people from different sides and it will
be their own words and either they will
have written it or we will have
taken it with a
tape recorder and print a transcript of
what they have to say
as far as your second question is
concerned i'm
if we got out of the war game
abruptly i would think that the
effect on the economy would be very uh
severe i mean the the military budget is
high even though
at least half of it goes to pay
salaries and a good or pensions and
is not exactly buying military hardware
but it's still it is a
big source of
[Music]
employment and of
money being generated through the
economy
i think we could survive it i don't
think that the i don't really think that
the economy would collapse
some people seem to think that i don't i
don't think that
i forget what the gnp is of the of our
weapons programs but it's it's not that
large
the soviet union of course
spends more proportionately than we do
but it's very uh it's very um
is a great burden on the
ussr be a wonderful thing if both
countries could begin to get out of the
business but
and i think both countries would survive
and do quite quite well
next call this morning winter haven
florida you're on the air
yes i have um kind of a related question
is it possible for
a daily newspaper to provide the sort of
historical context that mr lapham would
do in his magazine with the background
on issues and also on the teaching of
american government in classrooms and
governor hope government operates
is it possible to do that
without presenting a biased view of that
government
as opposed to economic systems or
capitalism and communism and such okay
let me ask you relative to your first
question
mr lappa made the point that there are
other sources of information available
if the public goes to seek them do you
seek out many different sources of
information other than daily newspapers
or tv newscasts
so i'm a professional journalist so i
try to read as much as possible but i've
always been concerned
in reporting the daily news that we
don't have time
or the background to provide any
historical context to what is happening
thanks for the call
i think it could be done technically of
course it could be done in a daily
newspaper if the newspaper
uh set up
a department or a signed three or four
reporters to do that with at least
one
story a day
and
the big papers of the times of course
does something like that when when a
crisis develops they will write a number
of sidebars and and give you a brief
chronology of the events leading up to
the present to the event in question and
they constantly print
uh status reports which show you the
number of soviet weapons as opposed to
the number of american weapons and if
they're if this story has got to do with
the signing of a treaty they will go
into some background
yes it can be done in a daily newspaper
as yet the newspapers are not as
they have again limited space and
they're trying to get as much
news into the
paper as possible
but there are things now being done in
the newspapers the op-ed pages the style
sections of let's say a paper like the
washington post or the new york times
or the front page
stories in the wall street journal 20 25
years ago those would have appeared in
harper's magazine those would have been
the kind of pieces that the magazines
did
now they're being done by the
the daily press so it's a continual
search on the part of the magazines to
stay to do something that the newspaper
can't do
more efficiently and at a cheaper price
you have to keep looking for a new
something
more mr lapland the caller's second
question was on
whether it's possible to teach
citizenship without bias but i have a
caller on the line so we'll get to that
after the next call los angeles good
morning you're on the air
yes mr lapin has suggested that
the media should be part of a source of
information uh to affect citizenship or
to inform citizens and uh i would like
to know uh how we could rely on a media
um that is willing to sensationalize its
findings for a commercial success uh a
media that now doesn't make any secret
of the fact that it believes it has the
right
not to report on what is happening on
the agenda so to speak but to set the
agenda to set the course for the country
though they have not been elected to do
this uh last year in an article in
esquire magazine um dan rather
it's called the man who married dan
rather it's about van gorden sauder and
uh
dan rather makes a statement that van
gorden sowder told him that the men who
watch the news and the fish bowl within
every night i told that's the room where
the big executives from cbs need to see
what their competitors are doing
uh that they said that they have about
as much to do with setting the national
agenda as any comparable group in
america now who elected them to do this
i mean if they didn't they would they
didn't say it both fully by the way and
that he wasn't self-conscious about it
was just the statement of fact he was
setting the agenda now when you get
people of cbs this powerful network uh
that has no competition except abc and
nbc i feel they have the right to to
direct our course to chart our cause
what kind of confidence can you have in
them giving you
our information unbiased information
that you might have for citizenship for
anything okay thanks los angeles
there is the problem of setting the
agenda and
she's right about that um
i don't know quite how that translates
into
much more than the
preoccupation of the press you still
have to get it from the preoccupation in
the media to
legislation or to the congress or to a
court
before it becomes
law
if it's a if it's a business deal that
you're talking about it obviously has to
go through the market i mean
so
yes the the
newspapers and the media can set the
agenda for what people talk about
for which
politicians face may appear on the front
page
on the other hand
it's still not clear to me and i've and
i've thought about this a lot into it's
to how far the media can carry that
through
in any sustained way to
[Music]
a specific
action or
legislation or
outcome of an election
the media has difficult
difficulties sustaining a cause or an
idea
or a purpose i mean it's it's it's
objective as some earlier caller said is
to is to entertain and and to
excite
not
also partly to instruct but the
instruction is is
less than the
entertainment part of it
with about 10 minutes left to go until
we take you to the smithsonian for the
george orwell symposium we go next to
sumter south carolina
hello yes sir you're on the air ah thank
you very much
uh i've got a lot of pinned up
frustrations and i'll try to be calm
i've been trying to get through to you
for weeks but anyway this is a excellent
time because i believe that the greatest
threat
to freedom in the united states of
america is the abuse of freedom and
that's the weakness of our
our freedoms is that it's so susceptible
abuse and the biggest abuser is the
media
the
they take the first amendment like
communists and crooks take the fifth
amendment
uh they distort views and i could give
hundreds examples they're obviously
against reagan
for instance you never hear reaganomics
anymore because reaganomics is working
i think they're responsible
for deaths in vietnam
along the vietnam war
uh
and and i i thank god that they didn't
let him in grenada because some idiot
would have probably reported everything
they were going to do
and i thank god that these people
weren't around during the normandy
invasion
and and i resent
the uh
and it's just terribly frustrating to
listen to them they distort everything
reagan says
for instance he says that
the communists were behind the
uh freeze movement well
he also said that there are a lot of
responsible people in the freeze
movement that really believe that this
is the way to go but the media doesn't
mention
that he said that all they say is he he
claims he makes this ridiculous claim
that the communists behind the freeze
movement well anybody that doesn't think
they're behind it or within it
is crazy
and why don't they publicize the fact
that reagan wants reduction
and well and communis the the communist
negotiators never mention reduction
you're making observations do you want
to know the question is
what you talk about he said don't blame
the media
uh we have no defense we have no defense
against these unelected people coming up
they're running our country
lying about our president uh
it's it's
they publicized jane fonda and ramsey
clark going to vietnam supporting the
communists supporting the enemy
and they they do not publicize the fact
that since we have less vietnam the
atrocities are a hundred fold as to what
they were and what our men were doing
over there was trying to prevent
starving people to death and murdering
them and enslaving them and they act
like that we they were over there for no
good purpose now that we've left there's
no reporting eli is like uh
uh it doesn't mean the thing compared to
what's going on now the slaughter how
would you like to be pushed out in the
countryside and told to live off the
land and starve to death nothing said
the boat people people put themselves
out in rickety boats and take a chance
that they
may be picked up trying to get away you
didn't have that even during the war in
vietnam caller i'm going to interrupt
you because we do understand your point
and we're running out of time we'll let
mr lapin respond thank you
well i
i see what he means but on the other
hand
he makes all those points and has all
that information he must have gotten it
somewhere so i assume he got it from
some form of media
and the
again if you read the
depends what paper you read if you read
the new york post it's a very pro
president reagan i have seen reagan's
proposals in the new york times and the
washington post for reduction of the
arms
there are columnists who support
reagan very articulately i have seen
jean kirkpatrick the ambassador at the
united nations make a long and eloquent
statement about the
present condition in in southeast asia
as opposed to
what it was when we were there so
i don't think it's as bad as
as that particular caller said because
that that particular caller is a
well-informed person and i had to find
out somewhere
going back to the question that our our
viewer who was a journalist from florida
asked about whether or not it was
possible to teach
citizenship without a bias
could you respond
yes i think it is it depends on what
you're talking about again it depends on
how you define the word i mean in
i guess you begin with with one question
an earlier caller asked which is
what does the united states stand for
what is it
what is the country about
what does it mean to be a citizen in
this in in this particular country
obviously it means something different
than to be a citizen if you can call of
the soviet union or of
france or italy
um
i think you can agree about that
you can yeah you could argue about it
but i mean once you you begin with that
kind of a
definition and then you can go on to
describe how the
how how
the government itself works as possible
without without too much uh bias you can
different people will suggest different
motives and assign different motives one
person will say that this is man is
doing this for this reason which may or
may not be true but the fact is that he
is doing x
oceanside california good morning
good morning
i'd like to make a comment here we have
students
in this country now that cannot read
do well and do not comprehend what they
do read
yet they watch tv and get the
commentators opinions
in my day in school
united states
history and current events were a
required subject
i think they should be required subjects
now from the fifth or sixth grade on
so these
youngsters will get
busy reading
and understanding what is going on in
this world
that's that's all i have would you make
comment on that okay thanks caller
well i would agree with that
and the problem of how to
restore american education is a
difficult problem and it's apparently
it's very uneven i've tried to find some
i've read
parts of many of the recent reports
about the
condition of the nation's schools and
most of them are
quite
pessimistic one or two of them are
optimistic and it
some schools
public schools still do teach american
history and current events others don't
[Music]
find it again it usually comes out of
the good
the ones that do it well it's because of
an impetus within the community
we have just about two minutes left time
for a quick question and a quick
response ironwood michigan good morning
good morning thank you i was glad to be
able to get on
i've enjoyed listening to the remarks
about the media people who feel that the
media is evil i am a newscaster myself i
didn't read a newspaper this morning but
i delivered five newscasts
and i just like to ask mr lapham if he
agrees or disagrees that 99 of the
reporters of america have too much
trouble getting the news to worry about
making opinions and changing people's
minds
i get a kick out of these people who
attack the media every which way they're
afraid of it if they don't like the
media if they want a sanitized newscast
a sanitized newspaper that never
criticizes or says anything about its
leaders is a nice little country called
albania
thank you thank you
i agree with him about the 99 i mean
it's
most of the complaints about the media
are really talking about a a a structure
a form
anything that
people are
caught up into and
i'd i notice i would not assign to the
media uh i would not call them villains
or evil people at all obviously
but there is the formulas that have to
be to be uh
observed there's only a limited amount
of space and time and there are things
that people will be interested more
people will be interested in than than
not i mean it's it's following the
american law of the market
and
i don't
um
again most of the people that complain
about the media seem to me to be
extremely well informed and i i think
therefore the media are some aspect of
the media has
media after all is plural so it's many
many instruments and
it's it's obviously doing its work with
the callers
thank you to lewis lapham editor of
harper's for joining us this morning to
give us in his insights into
1984 as he prepares for a speech that
you can hear this afternoon about 2 30
east coast time at the symposium at the
smithsonian on george orwell lewis
slapham again the editor of harper's
also is a syndicated columnist you can
look for his column around newspapers
around the country and he is currently
working on a book on religious and
superstitious uses of wealth in america
subject for a whole other hour i hope
you'll come back